un inesperado siempre lazo político
sacude a la coalición gobernante en
israel con la renuncia de inditex y una
parlamentaria del partido ya mina del
primer ministro naftalí bennett mediante
una carta y sin previo aviso silman
retiró su apoyo a la alianza
multipartidista alegando que causa daño
a la identidad judía de israel esto en
el marco de una disputa por los permisos
para que los pacientes puedan llevar
comida no kosher a los hospitales
durante la celebración durante los días
de la celebración de las pesas que la
pascua judía una excusa para muchos de
silván para poder diferenciarse de esta
coalición y llamar a formar un nuevo
gobierno de derecha en el que según los
medios locales ellas podría tener un
lugar preponderante como ministra de
salud el golpe tomó desprevenido al
ejecutivo de benet que de esta manera
pierde su mayoría en la knesset cuenta
ahora con 60 de los 120 escaños lo que
reduce su margen de maniobra para
sancionar leyes y le obliga a contar con
apoyos de la oposición aún así no parece
inminente una caída del gobierno una
caída de esta frágil alianza que está
conformada por ocho partidos
en junio pasado bajo un amplio espectro
ideológico y cuenta por primera vez con
presencia árabe esto porque el
parlamento se encuentra de receso y
tampoco está claro que el bloque de
derecha logre los 61 apoyos o ya sea
para formar un gobierno alternativo
dentro de esta legislatura o para
disolver el parlamento y convocar a
nuevas elecciones la renuncia fue
saludada por el hecho del primer
ministro benjamin netanyahu kim alentó a
otros legisladores a seguir el camino de
hillmán pese a estar afrontando un
juicio por cargos de corrupción el líder
del partido likud todavía aspira a
reunir a suficientes conservadores como
para formar un gobierno alternativo y
volver a ocupar el cargo que supo
ostentar durante 12 años